in the last episode of season's
greetings i measured myself against the
world's best at the santa winter games
in sweden but i didn't stand a chance
against some resolute opponents from
asia
not long to the big day now and the
appointments are piling up after my poor
showing at the santa winter games i'm
now even more determined to turn in a
good performance
my backdrop a christmas market in the
heart of berlin
the gendarmenmarkt event is one of the
most popular in the city every year
about 800 000 visitors come to the plaza
in the middle of the german capital
usually only experienced musicians or
performers appear on stage here though
centers are also welcome today that
means me after being introduced i hardly
have time to sit down before the kids
begin to arrive
you like the music should i write it
down
i can finally start to use everything i
learned from my santa friend in finland
how old are you
three and did you write a wish list
really
for me
i take the time to listen try to connect
with the kids and take their wishes
seriously reactions to my costume are
positive everywhere i go and the good
cheer isn't just coming from kids i can
also make adults happy who haven't
believed in santa for many years
next stop the christmas party at biko
koivaportal an online sales platform the
230 staff here have decided to celebrate
to a glam rock theme but i was able to
convince them to let me take charge for
a while playing santa for adults
presents a whole new range of different
challenges
would you get us in the mood and
this is very important
under circumstances will you make naomi
do this all alone
even though everyone has a copy of the
lyrics there are few minor problems with
the carols
where is little mario
mario cole is the managing director one
of the firm's two founders
and so you don't feel too lonely up here
where's little robin
robin billau is his business partner the
two have no idea what's going to happen
next i've only discussed that with their
employees
is it true that you really like to take
snapshots of yourself
to be able to take even better selfies
in the future i present little mario
with an extension rod that can hold his
smartphone
robin who is a big fan of german
schlager star helena fisher receives the
life-sized cardboard cutout of his idol
my gift to the staff the joke was on
their bosses
then it's time for the high point in any
santa's year christmas eve in germany
families traditionally open presents on
december 24th
hello
i hear there are a few children waiting
for me here can i come in
several hundred professional centers are
active in the city on this day some of
them have over a dozen appearances
scheduled compared to that my program is
a modest one
in many families playing christmas music
is an important tradition on this day
oh yeah very nice
then it's time to open the presents i've
spoken with the parents of the three
children in advance of course to make
sure there are no tears or
disappointments
we didn't forget anyone did
we did
i who if there's a present for you
of course there's a gift for the
youngest too in berlin a visit like mine
costs between 50 and 70 euros all in all
it only takes around 20 minutes
i've certainly learned a few things
about what it means to be a santa the
job is exhausting demanding and eventful
oh no my mission at santa claus is
already over so
it's time to take the beard off it's a
shame i had so much fun and i never met
so many friendly people and happy
children before have i been good well
it's not up to me to decide but anyway i
wish everyone a merry christmas and a
happy new year